[Music]
i i don't normally do these kind of
speeches but this feels like a big
moment
i know it's not easy being banished from
mi5 to my department
but that's on you only screw-ups get
sent to slaughterhouse and i've got to
be honest
working with you has been the lowest
point and a disappointing career
right
what are you looking for
the remnants of a once promising career
house is like prison you're not supposed
to ask what you're in for
i actually want to be useful i could not
be more bored if i tried you probably
know how many people have made it back
from slaughterhoused upstairs here at
regions park bringing you up the speeds
like trying to explain norway to a dog
none
come check this out hostage
he's being held here
there is something finally happening
what has it got to do with you
whatever's going on to be handled by the
real agents
i get it we're just slow horses i've got
one lead i have to follow them
from greece
[Music]
you're gonna help me oh no i'm not
like it or not our house is part of us
now
what do you think you're playing it
i didn't mean to kill him of course you
didn't if you meant to kill him he'd
still be alive
[Music]
you put lives in danger this is off the
books
i am directing personnel yours or
anybody else's
it's just covering our tracks
but it's the covering of the tracks it
always gets you in the end
you really care about them don't you
think you're a bunch of absolute losers
but they're my losers
[Music]
[Music]
you